boy beetlejuice has turned into a diva i
should uh play with this
my team recorded a bunch of material
with beetle after his last appearance
and as i say things do not go smoothly
our producer mike perlman asked beatle
to record an acceptance speech to play
if he were inducted into a hypothetical
whack pack hall of fame so
mike says hey beat
you know we're thinking of appointing
you the first winner of the whack pack
hall of fame and he's trying to explain
it to him and beat
beat seems insulted by it he didn't want
to even hear about it
listen all your success in your career
who do you want to thank you would you
like to thank your mom i don't want to
explain nothing y'all [ __ ]
y'all explain that [ __ ] to your mom i
don't do this [ __ ] man i do this [ __ ]
every damn day my mom take care of my
black ass is there something you want to
say about shawn though cause sean was
the one that could that found you shows
up in heaven man what the [ __ ] man let
the man [ __ ] rest and what about bob
you is there something you want to say
about bob
what the hell is your problem is there
anything you want to see your fans beat
there's so many people that like you
well they always say thank you they
already know who i am they always smile
and say i mean
how do you smell you're good you're good
can you say my fans no they ain't they
all my friends what do they what they
gotta worry about y'all some lazy
[ __ ] man
that's the truth
yeah you want me to do all the work why
don't you do some work we all know that
over the years we've gotten beatles to
somehow write great songs i mean it's
unbelievable he's a great songwriter and
richard tried his best to get another
hit out of betelgeuse but b was not
buying oh hey this was a disaster beat
just sing about making loves and making
love making love
ain't no making love we think this is
bad and sitting there and making love
yeah but you love marvin gaye sing like
marv
mama get his name that's simple
sing about when uh
people piss you off come on you can't
talk about these people like that what
the [ __ ] is your guy trying to do away
sal and richard were trying so hard to
be nice to beat but b kept calling them
dumbasses which i kind of thought was
funny yeah that was great so the next we
tried to get beat to play a game and
that didn't go well either can you name
a pizza topping pizza topper i need your
pizza topping with my dick on top of
their pizza i have that
what's your favorite kind of pizza to
eat
oh what kind of pizza how you like the
sauce on my [ __ ]
how's that
how's that sound
oh my god and then uh my birthday was
coming up we figured well let's get beat
to wish me a happy birthday and and put
one in the can for your birthday
and forget it didn't want to wish me a
happy birthday they want to wish you a
happy birthday and he likes me and he
likes you i mean
forget it can you wish howard stern a
happy birthday go ahead yeah until i
happen to kiss his ass
say how would happen tell him
howard happy birthday i know it's his
birthday i know you think i'm not dumb
happy new year's your [ __ ]
you don't wish robin a happy birthday
robin happy birthday robin oh yeah try
to get some ass okay
happy new years to you happy new years
to you robert and everything kiss your
blast
[Laughter]
beetlejuice i love that guy